barbara n'est plus la dame en noir à la
voix de cristal vient de disparaître à
l'âge de 67 ans retour sur sa carrière
témoignages reportages complets dans ce
journal
réforme de la sécurité sociale à bitche
en moselle un hôpital de proximité va
devoir fermer un certain nombre de
services
les personnels des usagers autres pas
d'accord les retraités dans la rue à
paris aujourd'hui dans plusieurs villes
de france à l'appel des syndicats qui ne
veulent plus qu'on les considère comme
des privilégiés de cette fin de siècle à
paris des policiers sur les traces d'un
tueur en série qui sévit dans l'est de
la capitale trois affaires de jeunes
femmes assassinées dans les mêmes
conditions ont été réunies
cinéma walt disney nous livre son dessin
animé de fin d'année hercules revu et
corrigé le héros de la mythologie
grecque perd un peu de son quotient
intellectuel au profit d'une musculature
renforcée madame monsieur bonsoir
barbara vient de disparaître à l'âge de
67 ans la dame en noir à la voix de
cristal comme une fragile comme une rose
n'est plus mais sa voix pour nous
restera toujours aussi haut perchée que
l'aigle noir
george v
où
jours
je mettais la longue dame brune s'est
endormi mais sa voix nous parlera
longtemps à l'oreille car tel était le
talent de barba va donner à chacun
l'illusion d'être son confident il ne
pleut pas seulement sur nantes
aujourd'hui
pétri de mélancolie mais aussi écorché
bible barbara qui avait d'abord
interprété les chansons des autres semi
un jour peut être une nuit à écrire ses
textes toujours en quête d'amour mal à
les gens qui ne veulent pas ils veulent
pas aimer ou qui ne veulent pas ou ne
veulent pas et qu'il faut aller chercher
comme ça
en reviendrait
néanmoins le ctu
dans le documentaire la gueule
tout le temps peur d'une
ce retour je crois que j'ai créé une
chanson comme une lettre pour que je
crie ville faut que je vive voir tant de
gens qui dorment et s'endorment nuit
finirez par contrainte il faut que je
m'endorme aussi importants que ceux qui
se ferme
je vais pouvoir endormez bosser j'en ai
connu les grands des mots des biens
bâtis des gens qui venaient pour bbc
combattre mais un revenu les hommes
qu'en pensez-vous je les aime je les
aime
conques où j'ai besoin du plus haut rayé
les saisons je t'apprendrai les ardentes
apprendrait la douceur d'une main sur
mon cou
quand même
nous je t'attendrai pour une longue dame
brune
j'ai inventé
bonjour je suis la dame brune je t'es
trompé
la place entre deux volets
tiens en chant
rien à l'abri
les chansons d'amour par exemple étaient
les choses auxquelles je ne pourrais pas
touché parce que c'était les chansons
d'amour écrites par des hommes et ce
n'était pas comme ça
barbara avait des convictions et les
affirmait l'homme à la rose lui avait
inspiré une chanson elle était engagée
depuis dix ans dans une action de
soutien aux malades du sida
elle s'intéressait aussi aux femmes sans
paysans et aux enfants malheureux après
un silence de 16 ans elle remontait sur
scène et publié son treizième album en
février dernier une victoire de la
musique l'a couronné dis quand
reviendras-tu barbara dans le petit bois
de saint-amand
le bar est morte donc hier soir à
l'hôpital américain de neuilly où elle
avait été admise dimanche victime d'un
choc toxique infectieux dont l'évolution
s'est révélé foudroyante dès ce matin à
l'annoncé du décès de nombreuses
personnalités sont venues lui rendre un
dernier hommage
le premier ministre et le président de
la république se sont également exprimés
pour jacques chirac la voix de barbara
nous manque déjà elle était dit-il le
talent et la passion eric lemasson
arnaud boutet dès l'annoncé de la mort
de barbara quelques admirateurs triste
sont venus une rose à la main écrire
leur chagrin sur le livre de
condoléances ouvert à l'hôpital
américain
parmi ses admirateurs carla bruni le
mannequin parmi ses amis depardieu
l'acteur qui serait discrètement venu ce
matin amis aussi line renaud
visiblement très éprouvé
si on était très unie dans le même genre
l'heure où le même combat
depuis des années le faisait d'une autre
façon et visiter les prisons encore la
semaine dernière je l'avais eue au
téléphone elle était très bien
barbara est morte hier soir malgré une
journée de réanimation pour la faire
revenir à la vie
en vain choc toxi-infection eu
d'évolution foudroyante ce sont les mots
des médecins sur les causes du décès
mais peu importe les termes il signifie
que barbara n'est plus et qu'aujourd'hui
les plus hautes autorités du pays salue
sa mémoire par caractère parfois
étranges deux de ses textes et de sa
personnalité par la fragilité de sa voix
par l'exigence aussi de ce qu'elle
chante elle ne semblait pas a priori
être forcément au départ une chanteuse
populaire et en même temps elle a touché
des foules immenses précy-sur-marne
village d'ile-de-france se souvient
aussi de barbara la chanteuse avait élu
domicile il y a vingt ans dans une
ancienne ferme du bourg
elle était très discrète ne l aimait pas
beaucoup la côtoyer les gens mais
seulement ce qu'il ya c'est que tout ce
qu'à la prochaine
c'était une femme un registre de
condoléances a été ouvert à la mairie du
village
le hasard a voulu que le maire de précy
sur marne soit lui aussi un chanteur
connu s'est occupé de participer à des
actions en faveur des personnes âgées un
foreur des jeunes contre le sida en
faveur des enfants elle a participé aux
cadeaux des enfants en fait sa
discrétion cache une très grande
générosité
elle avait besoin de se sentir utile
loin des lumières de la scène
barbara vivent est ici solitaire et
discrète ses voisins avaient remarqué
que les volets verts de la longue dame
brune ne s'ouvraient jamais après des
études de chant classique barbara la
discrète qui n'avait qu'un seul amour le
public fréquenta les cabarets avant les
grandes salles sa voix très particulière
donner le sentiment de pouvoir se briser
à chaque instant tous ses amis
s'accordent pour dire qu'elle n'a pas
créé
un style son talent était unique il le
restera louis carzou nicolas van le
public
telle était la plus grande histoire
d'amour de barbara ce public fidèle
amoureux qui a suivi les tours et
détours de la dame en noir depuis ses
débuts à lécluse jusqu'à son retour au
théâtre du châtelet mais barbara
nourrissait aussi d'autres passions avec
la même fidélité le même secret celle
qu'elle partageait avec les poètes des
les musiciens heureux élus de son regard
de sa voix
j'ai fait une chanson pour elle pour lui
chanter à m
il a voulu me répondre et donc c'est
devenu un duo et je paie plus la chanter
sans elle ne peut pas la chanter sur moi
ce qui fait que dans la logistique
ensemble et on est passé à un premier
ensemble je fais de longues tournées
lesquels juste pour chanter ce duo parce
que c'est l'un et l'autre étaient
devenus indispensables une longue dame
brune fait inventer
une chance au clair de la lune
quelques couplets elles étaient hors de
la mode hors du temps et la seule chose
qui comptait pour s était de traduire
une vibration de sentiment d'être
d'êtres humaines ce qui m'a surpris
c'est d'avoir une vie à une copine
c'était une amie aussi une amour mais
une copine de cet âge là quoi de pouvoir
chanter avec elle de voir aucune
différence et aucune différence avec la
musique que je faisais aussi la manière
de faire
lourd
la dernière fois que je les ai eus au
téléphone c'était pour lui dire que
j'avais une page blanche que j'arrive
plus à jamais à écrire et que j'avais
l'impression de radoter elle m'a dit
mais tout le monde a droit au doute et
moi qu'est ce que tu crois que je fais
charlotte barbey les mots me manquent
pour te dire tout ce que j'ai à te dire
j'ai pensé que peut-être manvieu nous
ferez mieux que moi alors j'ai juste un
petit mot ressentent
non
barbara que nous retrouverons à la fin
de ce journal
les autres grands titres de l'actualité
aujourd'hui après la sphère de la
fermeture de l'hôpital de pithiviers qui
fut réglée à chaud après une erreur
médicale
la nouvelle carte des hôpitaux français
se met en place à bitche en moselle
l'opération de fermeture d'un certain
nombre de services de cet établissement
de proximité se fait à froid donc dans
le cadre de la réforme globale de la
sécurité sociale mais comme à pithiviers
elle provoque également un certain
nombre de réactions chez les usagers et
parmi le personnel hospitalier reportage
d'olivier caroff alain locaux gaëtan
aurélie périnée à big eyes il n'y aura
plus d'autres nouveaux nés à l'hôpital
de bitche le couperet administratif est
tombé dans huit jours les 25 places en
maternité et les 22 lits de chirurgie
devons être vide
j'en ai gros sur le coeur
vraiment je n'arrive pas encore à y
croire je n'avais pas réalisé depuis ce
matin interdiction pour ce petit hôpital
d'accepter de nouveaux patients sauf en
cas d'extrême urgence
ils devront aller dans d'autres villes à
quelques jours près c'est ce qui
attendait cette famille il faudra qu'on
fasse sur un banc
j'espère que si si ça se produit
j'aurais pas accouché en hiver
vraiment désastreux chez nous un
argument qui laisse de marbre les
responsables régionaux de la santé
leur argument la sécurité avant tout
pourquoi cette décision
essentiellement pour des raisons de
sécurité sanitaire puisque elle concerne
ces raisons de sécurité sanitaire temps
la prise en charge en anesthésie au sein
de l'hôpital que l'organisation des
activités de chirurgie et gynécologie
obstétrique en clair pas assez de
chirurgie un nid d'anesthésistes pour
opérer sans danger à l'hôpital de bitche
on rappelle qu aucun incident grave
n'est intervenu en 15 ans et que des
postes en plus ça fait longtemps qu'on
en demande on m'a demandé à par exemple
un deuxième anesthésiste il ya des âmes
anesthésistes et nous n'ont pas donné
pourquoi pas simplement parce qu' il
dise qu'on travaille pas assez
la rentabilité a donc joué un rôle dans
la fermeture et c'est peut-être le plus
difficile à admettre dans cette ville de
5000 habitants qui a perdu coup sur coup
sa gare sncf et son régiment de
fantasmes l'insécurité dans les
transports en commun aujourd'hui c'est à
brest en bretagne qu'une partie des
chauffeurs se sont mis en grève après
que des véhicule et suivis des jets de
pierres dans la soirée d'hier dans
l'agglomération brestoise à mulhouse en
alsace le trafic a repris aujourd'hui
après l'arrêt de travail de 24 heures
suite à des violences trafics sous bonne
escorte avec l'arrivée d'importants
renforts de policiers et de crs
reportage testing boss sylvain gauthier
débuts sous escorte policière sur les
trajets sensible ça peut avoir l'air un
peu solennel mais ça n'impressionne
apparemment pas tout le monde
plus imposant le déploiement de crs 130
hommes une dizaine de véhicules répartis
dans les quartiers sensibles de mulhouse
un dispositif sécuritaire visibles dont
le but est de rassurer des usagers et
surtout les conducteurs de bus qui ont
tous repris leur service
aujourd'hui la aujourd'hui ça a été très
efficace mais parce qu'on a eu aucun
problème
c'était calme dans le bus il n'y a pas
eu de problème au niveau aux arrêts rien
c'était très calme
même constant auprès des usagers
pourtant sceptiques sur l'efficacité des
mesures
je pense que de deux d'engager des
jeunes comme
comme agent d'ambiance les jeunes des
quartiers eux mêmes qui sont
responsables même je pense que ça c'est
là c'est une bonne solution
des jeunes pour qui ce déploiement de
force s'apparente à de la provocation
car ces incidents surviennent à dix
jours d'une législative partielle où le
front national a tout à gagner pour les
élections comme le mec qui veut dire
ouais on est dans l'insécurité ou quoi
que ce soit alors qu'il va faire il va
mettre la pression et c'est pareil c'est
psychologique tout ça vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est psychologique il va
fermer ta présente sur les jeunes les
jeunes vous commencent à se défouler et
va dérouiller vous voyez la sécurité
donc voté pour moi on donne tout et est
calculé c'est vraiment vous fait
vraiment attention c'est au personne
n'est dupe ici mais le risque de
dérapage lui est bien réel mais y'en a
un public a terminé aujourd'hui son
voyage en guyane dans ce département
français d'outre-mer situés en amérique
du sud est qui connaît d'importants
problèmes de chômage
un habitant sur deux a moins de 25 ans
là-bas et le chef de l'état a eu un
dialogue qui n'avait rien de
conventionnel avec des jeunes qu'il
avait réuni autour de lui et qui ont
donc exprimé à leur façon leur problème
carole common jacques gregor rassurer la
jeunesse d'un département miné par le
chemin le pari était difficile
deux heures d'une discussion à bâtons
rompus souvent graves et parfois
surprenantes
la morale oui pourquoi est elle partie n
est plus là
ses parents partis alors c'était un bon
moyen de développer l'esprit des jeunes
c'était c'était un bon moyen n'était pas
et pour ce dialogue avec les jeunes
français de guyane
jacques chirac a aussitôt trouvé le
soutien de l'un des leurs amours rien
n'est de savoir saisir la perche et
d'aller un peu plus loin à bout jeunes
aujourd'hui donc saisir votre chance
comme moi j'ai pu la saisir un moment
donné une rencontre qui intervient un an
tout juste après la révolte lycéenne qui
avait secoué la guyane depuis les jeunes
ont eu leur rectorat mais pour parler
d'avenir
il hésite encore entre découragement
malaise et désespoir il existe un
véritable gouffre entre la guyane tels
que vous avez pu la voir à proulx et le
reste de la guyane et je voudrais savoir
qu'est ce que vous proposez concrètement
pour que cet équilibre soit à nouveau
rétablie et que la guyane et fassent
plus qu'une
nous sommes les oubliés de la france
veut sauver président il ne faut plus
dire nous somme misérable
il faut dire nous sommes fantastique et
nous allons le prouver
et quand nous l'aurons prouver alors
nous serons fondé à dire il peut nous
donner un coup de main un ton qui se
voulait d'abord mobilisateur tous les
jeunes ne sont sans doute pas repartis
totalement convaincu mais beaucoup ont
pour le moins été sensible à la démarche
aux problèmes de débouchés pour cette
jeunesse guyanaise s'ajoute aujourd'hui
le cas d'environ 20% des enfants issus
de pays frontaliers comme le surinam ou
le brésil des enfants qui sont peu
scolarisés pratiquement à l'alphabet tu
marques maisons neuves à la poigne 8h30
un matin comme les autres pour ces
enfants là mais meurent dans la rue mais
pour eux il n'y a pas de place à l'école
lequel va pas à l'école à quoi je sais
rien il ne parle que la langue locale le
takita qui comme 600 autres enfants qui
eux non plus n'ont pas de place en cours
savoir que depuis quelques années par
année ses 10 15 voire vienne big band
classe où nous construisons chaque année
actuellement nous sommes arrivés au
point nous n'avons plus les moyens de
construire ni même d'entretenir ce que
nous avons construit il ya quelques
années
johnny s'est réfugié en guyane avec sa
famille il vient du surinam en cinq ans
saint laurent du maroni est passé de
5000 à 15 mille habitants et même si la
moitié de la population est en âge
scolaire les crédits n'ont pas suivi mes
trajets des panels place encore plus
folle et le gas oil
qu'est ce qui fonde la journée en guyane
20% de la population est analphabète
dans cette école ces enfants sont
français même si pour la plupart leurs
parents viennent du surinam ou du guyana
en entrant en classe ils apprennent
qu'un français spécialement adaptée
avant les maths ou les sciences
naturelles
je suis parti d'un support j'irai un
local utilisé des méthodes qui a été
créé et conçu localement mais je
travaille aussi sur le catalogue des
outils qu'ils ont la mettons les
premiers temps il n'y a pas que les
enfants qui ont un peu de mal à
s'adapter
je comprends pas vos textes écrits par
les oiseaux jusqu'en sixième
les enfants ne manquent jamais l'école
car ils savent qu'ici avoir une place et
un privilège manifestation de retraités
à l'appel des syndicats aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs villes de france et à paris
principalement les retraités sont
aujourd'hui souvent considérés comme des
privilégiés leurs représentants ne sont
pas d'accord avec cette image car les
situations sont vraiment très différente
selon les secteurs damien thévenot
dominique bonnet qui malgré la fatigue
et une arthrose douloureuse
louis les gens ont tenu à manifester
cinquante ans de mariage est en retraite
depuis 15 ans lorsqu'il était cadre
moyen dans la fonction publique
louise et j'en étais bien loin
d'imaginer qu'il serait obligé un jour
de descendre dans la rue aujourd'hui
nous étions certain nombre de dents de
reprêter qui serait provisions est prêt
à ce pack puisque de terme s'impose de
lui-même pour avoir droit quand même un
autre et ceux du pour lequel ils se
battent s'appelle pouvoir d'achat en 15
ans ce couple estime avoir perdu 20 % de
ses revenus
rds csg cotisation maladie autant de
près les ventes sont venus amputé le
budget famille
malgré un revenu total de quinze mille
francs par mois le couple est inquiet
pour son avenir
nos rémunérations de retraite ne nous
permettrait même pas de payer ce qui est
la moyenne des maisons de retraite
bénéficiant d'un séjour médicalisé une
situation qui préoccupe l'ensemble des
retraités
même si au niveau statistique la
tendance est à l'amélioration
dans les 10 % de la population française
qui sont le moins à l'aise et bahia
encore un tir de retraités alors il ya
quinze ans il y avait 50% donc
l'amélioration est certaine mais
évidemment il faudrait pas voir les
retraités comme avon homogène
exclusivement formé de personnes qui
sont à l'aise économiquement
dans le fond on sait assez bien où sont
aujourd'hui les groupes de retraités qui
sont les moins à l'aise ce sont les plus
âgées notamment les femmes les veuves
celles qui ont des pensions de réversion
qui sont encore assez faible
la france compte aujourd'hui 16 millions
de plus de 50 ans ils passeront à 22
millions dans dix ans la grève des
traminots d'euros en est à son treizième
jour elles portent sur le respect d'un
accord sur le temps de travail et
l'embauché de nouveaux employés signé
l'année dernière
l'accord qui n'est toujours pas
appliquée les discussions se sont
engagées aujourd'hui mais pour l'instant
elles n'ont débouché sur aucun résultat
la brigade criminelle de paris vient
d'obtenir que trois affaires
d'assassinats de jeunes femmes non
résolus et d'une tentative soient
regroupés ils sont en effet de plus en
plus persuadés qu'ils ont affaire à un
tueur en série qui sévit dans l'est de
la capitale
la dernière victime en date âgé de 25
ans a été retrouvée morte chez elle
c'était dimanche dernier en quête
valérie fournier raymond chapelât loin
des regards et à l'abri de la foule du
faubourg saint-antoine où le tueur a
choisi cette arrière-cour pour commettre
son premier meurtre
le 10 décembre 1994 au soir agnès neige
campe 32 ans rentrait seule chez elle le
tueur la nuit où l'attend en tout cas
ils n'entrent pas par effraction dans
son appartement
le lendemain ce que les inspecteurs de
la brigade criminelle découvriront une
vision saisissante
agnès a eu la gorge tranchée après avoir
été violée six mois plus tard il
récidive
mais cette fois échoué le tueur utilise
pourtant les mêmes méthodes d' approche
entre dans l'appartement d'elisabeth et
la ligote pieds et poings liés elle
réussira pourtant à lui échapper le
tueur en porte un sac dans sa fuite
un sac retrouvé deux rues plus loin par
le concierge de cet immeuble au fond de
ce couloir
dans ce meuble pour savoir qu avait
elle-même bla le net il fallait que
quelqu'un soit déjà venus et pareil que
j'ai repris la mer en tout cas ils tuent
dans le coin oui alors connaître les
enquêteurs sont parvenus à la même
conclusion
il aurait si d'elisabeth seul témoin
leur permet alors d'esquisser son profil
le tueur s'exprime bien et froid
méthodique toujours polis un portrait
robot est dessiné dès le 19 juin 95
diffusé dans tous les commissariats
il représente un homme de 25 30 ans
d'origine méditerranéenne
les policiers ont même sa case identité
son adn mais les attentats de paris les
mobilise et le tueur recommence le 8
juillet suivant hélène fring king 27 ans
j'affirme et qu'en fin juillet 95 les
autorités savaient qu'ils étaient en
phase naturelle en syrie un homme
extrêmement dangereux et que en toute
bonne logique de serial killer on
pouvait s'attendre à ce qu'il recommence
et c'est en juillet 95 qu'il aurait
fallu mettre beaucoup plus d'effectifs
sur le sur la sphère et le fuck
enfin fin septembre 23 septembre 97
c'est-à-dire 26 mois après il y ait ce
nouveau meurtre de magali c'est quelque
chose que je ne supporte pas geffray
dans une idée que c'était c'était de
trop et et magali n'aurait jamais dû
mourir
magali avait 19 ans 23 septembre 97
lorsqu'elle a été tuée par le même homme
c'est l'adn qui une fois encore le
prouve
de même pour l'ultime victime du tueur
estelle mag
le 16 novembre dernier le procès du
réseau des complices des terroristes
islamistes du gia à paris a repris à son
début aujourd'hui car le président a été
obligé de changer d'assesseurs le
premier étant tombés malades
michel giraud ancien sous préfet de
pithiviers pendant la guerre vient de
faire condamner sept journaux et une
radio qu'il avait mise en cause dans le
transfert de centaines de familles
juives internées dans ce camp de
pithiviers michelle génois toujours
affirmé qu'il n'avait aucune compétence
sur ce camp la justice lui a donc donné
raison
la ville de montpellier dans l'hérault
s'est retrouvé ce matin subitement sous
les eaux après un très violent orage qui
a mobilisé l'ensemble des pompiers de la
région certaines routes ont même été
coupée karine comme a dit pascal 15 en
jargon météo on appelle ça une ligne de
grains pour l'automobiliste
montpelliérain c'est tout simplement une
excellente raison d'être en retard au
travail en effet l'équivalent d'un mois
de pluie automnale s'est abattu entre 7h
et 9h ce matin le lez et la mousson sont
sortis de leur lit et ont envahi les
parties basses de la boule et pourtant
200 pompiers de montpellier et des
environs sont intervenus sans relâche
journée au total près de 700 opérations
de pompage dans les seules salles du
centre-ville sur un but contre 1 8h30
leurs trousses à dijon plaît si vous
voulez au niveau de la chaudière en bas
et du brûleur quand complet le niveau de
l'eau est arrivée à aux couleurs ça
disjoncte et donc si je comprenais pas
et j'ai trouvé en élimination des
d'énergie j'ai trouvé que ça venait de
vaca donc je suis descendu à la cave et
j'avais de l'eau j'avais 5 cm de haut en
bas et ça va laurent très ciblés depuis
la voirie parler soupirail d'aération de
ventilation du câble ce soir le maire de
montpellier demande le constat de
catastrophe naturelle pour sa ville
de son côté météo france prévoit une
nouvelle nuit de pluie
le ministre français des affaires
étrangères hubert védrine poursuit son
périple au moyen-orient à israël il est
arrivé aujourd'hui dans les territoires
palestiniens pour s'entretenir avec
yasser arafat
la situation économique des territoires
palestiniens est aujourd'hui alarmante
dans la mesure où la tension avec
jérusalem empêche les travailleurs de
sortir des territoires à gaza notamment
le blocus plus ou moins partielle de ces
derniers mois touche en premier lieu les
enfants reportage charles envers gaza la
clinique de l'association terre des
hommes
le maintien ces enfants souffrent de
malnutrition
ils reçoivent ici un complément de
vitamines et de protéines selon nos
statistiques
à gaza les cas de malnutrition chez les
enfants ont augmenté de 34% dans les
camps de réfugiés depuis le début de
l'année c'est la conséquence directe du
chômage catastrophiques qui règne à gaza
plus de 70% dans les camps au cours des
dix derniers - ce territoire a été
totalement bouclée par l'armée
israélienne pendant 88 jours est
actuellement seuls vingt mille ouvriers
de plus de 35 ans vont au travail en
israël pour une population d'un million
d'habitants les premiers à souffrir de
cette situation sont les plus faibles
les enfants qui ont des maladies
chroniques aïda par exemple est
allergique au gluten et ne peut manger
le pain qui constitue l'essentiel de
l'alimentation de la famille son père
ancien détenu ne peut se rendre en
israël
il est au chômage regardez ce que nous
mangeons des lentilles du riz la farine
mais chut on a créé but nous payons
l'épicerie jacqueline est un peu
d'argent
à l'hôpital pédiatrique de gaza les
médecins constatent que les cas de
malnutrition grave ont augmenté d'un
tiers depuis le début de l'année les
parents de shenyang n'ont pas les moyens
de la nourrir avec le lait végétal
qu'elles supportent ils ont alimenté
avec de l'eau sucrée
comme dans ce cas la malnutrition mène à
des déficiences immunitaires donc à des
infections
c'est un cercle vicieux dans les camps
de réfugiés on ne parle pas devant la
caméra du train de vie des dirigeants
palestiniens de l'aide internationale
insuffisante blocage du processus de
paix les palestiniens perdent l'espoir
au japon après la faillite de la plus
grosse société de courtage la bourse de
tokyo a baissé de plus de 5% aujourd'hui
et d'autres entreprises financières
vivent dans l'angoissé d'une faillite au
point que des milliers de japonais sont
venus dès ce matin réclamé avec force
leurs économies qu'ils avaient placées
dans cette société
des scènes comme celle ci se sont
répétés ce matin alors que les
responsables de la société en pays
tentaient de rétablir l'ordre
devant les comptoirs avec beaucoup de
mal vous le constatez le premier ennui
politique du premier ministre anglais
tony blair qui sort sur les sondages
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir ne vient
pas du tout dans l'attende en effet
c'est sa femme qui est accusée d'avoir
voulu se séparer du chat offrait le plus
ancien locataire du 10 downing street la
résidence des premiers ministres
britanniques
cela peut paraître un peu ridicule mais
la sphère est en train de prendre un
tour politique puisque le times
l'équivalent du journal le monde en
angleterre fait aujourd'hui un titre à
la une avec cette affaire londres et
diana
imaginez les conseillers en
communication de lionel jospin obligé de
convoquer télévision et photographes
dans un lieu tenu secret pour attester
quotidien du jour à l'appui que la
mascotte de la politique nationale est
toujours vivante
cette histoire forcément britannique et
sur réaliste mais elle est authentique
la semaine dernière la très puissante
presse anglaise commencent à s'inquiéter
et le fait savoir
humphrey locataire du 10 downing street
depuis dix ans au moins c'est tout
simplement volatilisé
tout y passe interview télévisée des
bobbies de faction nous sommes tous très
inquiets on n'a pas vu depuis un moment
tony blair est interpellé ou est en prêt
car dans le rôle de cruella toute la
presse soupçonne la femme de monsieur
blair chérie de s'être tout simplement
débarrassé d'une crèche dont elle ne
supporterait pas la présence le chat est
malade comme un chien il a été déplacé
proteste le service de presse
vétérinaire à l'appui mais les journaux
se déchaînent trop peureux de
déstabiliser des conseillers jugé
arrogant hommes frais ce matin encore
est à la une des quotidiens les plus
sérieux qui demande maintenant que
l'authenticité du mammifère qu'on leur a
présenté soit génétiquement établi au
jeu du chat et de la souris que ce libre
perpétuellement en grande-bretagne
journalistes et conseillers en
communication politique est bien la
presse vient de marquer les points en
prouvant que son pouvoir de nuisance
pouvait se nicher jusque sous les
coussinets d'un chat miracle à palerme
en sicile aujourd'hui un immeuble
vétuste de quatre étages une
centre-ville s'est écroulé les surfeurs
ont pu heureusement dégagé vivant trois
enfants qui avaient été pris sous les
décombres cinq familles vivaient dans
cet immeuble de palerme tout le monde
paie donc
sains et saufs en italie centrale après
les tremblements de terre d'il y a 2
mois maintenant les travaux de réfection
du patrimoine artistique de la basilique
saint françois d'assise sont en course
et avec une précision infinie que les
spécialistes tentent de réparer des
dégâts très importants qui a subi
l'édifice secoué à plusieurs reprises il
faut s'en souvenir rome alain de chalon
depuis le 26 septembre depuis que quatre
personnes ont trouvé la mort ici lors de
la deuxième secousse du tremblement de
terre
toute présence est interdite dans la
basilique d'assise le fait des petits
morceaux de la voûte continue tombé la
terre ne cesse de trembler mais avec des
téléobjectifs et des instruments
particuliers architectes et
restaurateurs ont pu scruter les
inestimables presque deux autos et si ma
bouée elle se retrouvèrent qu'une
poussière qui les rend méconnaissable
mais aucune fissure apparent aucune
vision est réversible l'effondrement
d'une partie des voûtes tous les dégâts
sont réparables la basilique inférieure
plus protégés a été rouverte aux
restaurateurs
les fresques en particulier celles de le
chiot tôt par reste intacte les fissures
bien sûr on est plutôt légère le mal est
plus sournois le tremblement de terre a
provoqué un décollement des fraises par
rapport aux murs de city alors
centimètre carré de par centimètre carré
on cherche à l'oreille les creux les
creux sam baum de décollement aussitôt
on fait un petit trou dans la fresque et
on injecte une colle qui va la faire
adhérer à nouveau au mur une technique
éprouvée qui prend simplement du temps
en un mois on a pu traiter 200 m² de
fresques l'ensemble de la basilique en
compte plus de 10000 mais ainsi on
devrait pouvoir sauver l'essentiel ce
qui vaut pour les humains malades vaut
pour les restaurations on peut guérir a
beaucoup de maladies mais après tout
n'est pas forcément exactement comme
avant si la même chose pour les fresques
murales reste les voûtes qui sont
tombées l'une était du hachis mabhouh et
l'autre attribue à kyoto a priori le
malt irrémédiable et pourtant non tous
les fragments été récoltés ici et prier
comme un gigantesque puzzle
on a déjà réussi à reconstituer une
partie du visage par ci par là à la main
et à l'oeil
mais le gros du travail sera confiée à
l'informatique
tous les fragments ou groupes de
fragments seront saisis sur un
ordinateur par canalisations après quoi
ce sera l'ordinateur qui fera le puzzle
de tous ces fragments cij yoto s'était
douté en travaillant ici en 13 sans que
son oeuvre serait un jour sauver par des
microprocesseurs
réunion en présence du premier ministre
aujourd'hui à l'hôtel matignon pour
tenter de mobiliser les français autour
de la coupe du monde de football qui
débutera pas très longtemps maintenant
le 10 juin proches à cette occasion on a
débattu d'un problème qui n'est pas
encore tranché celui de la présence ou
non d'un grillage pour séparer joueurs
et spectateurs sur les stades la
tendance actuelle serait plutôt à la
suppression ce grillage en comptant sur
un changement d'état d'esprit des
spectateurs qui reste encore à démontrer
il faut bien le dire finie visseyrias
raymond chaplin chaque but provoque une
marée humaine pour empêcher
l'envahissement des terrains depuis des
années en france
des grilles isole les supporters dans
les tribunes une image qui choque la
fédération internationale de football
selon elle puisque la france organise la
coupe du monde qu'elle offre donc de ces
stades une image plus convivial
terminées les spectateurs en cage
le comité français d'organisation et du
même avis moi je suis favorable jeudi
aux philosophiquement à une suppression
des grilles je pense que le peuple
français est prêt à
trouvé dans un stade sans grillage pour
étudier la question
le gouvernement a demandé à rené georges
querry inspecteur général de la police
nationale de faire le tour des dix
stades de la coupe du monde malgré son
rapport a été remis au ministre de
l'intérieur qui doit prendre la décision
les greens peut-être enlevé que 502
conditions sont réunies ce à raison pour
laquelle on y accueillir ce mouvement
est en surnombre par les décisions tout
est possible si les conditions sont
réunies les conditions dépendent de la
structure des stades
on va donc faire du cas par cas
aujourd'hui le ministre des sports a
précisé qu'au moins sept des dix stades
devraient être dépourvu de grille
là où il n'y a pas de fossé séparant le
terrain des tribunes un système de
filins horizontaux déjà en place au
stade de wembley en angleterre pourrait
être installé tout cela complété par des
agents de sécurité et les caméras de
vidéosurveillance
mais la solution la plus originale a été
trouvé par le stade de france
les grilles modulable un métro 10 en
position normal de mettre 20 pour les
matches à risques en europe de football
premier match d'une équipe de france est
ce soir auxerre rencontré aux pays bas
l'équipe de twenty bien aussi elle a
emporté avec ce but de diomède à la 70e
minute de la rencontre victoire
d'auxerre 1 à 0 on voit le but au
ralenti très beau but 70e minute
victoire importante pour les auxerrois
si les mains et walt disney qui nous
livre chaque année à la même époque son
dessin animé de noël présente hercule le
héros de la mythologie grecque un
personnage revu et corrigé par
l'amérique dans le scénario hercules a
perdu un peu de son quotient
intellectuel pour se rapprocher de
monsieur muscle nicole quand des langues
jeu il me semble que vous avez besoin et
bains hérault
ouais et t'es qui toi
je m'appelle hercules et il se trouve
que je sais ce demi-dieu muscles hince
des kills rond depuis sa plus tendre
enfance avec son copain pégase dans les
bras de son père de ce maître de
l'univers et de sa femme
ra qui n'est pas sa mère puisqu'il est
le fils d'une mortelle ac mène son
destin tumultueux sera bien différent de
ces images de bonheur au bluff pour
s'imprégner de cette histoire de
l'antiquité
l'équipe de walt disney s'est déplacé
jusqu'à athènes pour retrouver les
traces des reculs la réalité
contemporaine étant bien loin de la
mythologie
les réalisateurs ont hésité entre
liberté ou authenticité par rapport à la
légende
en fait nous avons fait un mélange nous
sommes venus ici il ya deux ans nous
avons sur quoi on la grèce nous sommes
remontés jusqu'aux personnes au ladakh
et nous avons tourné dans la ville
nous voulions respecter la mythologie
montrer le combat entre l'homme et le
dieu ces difficultés à vivre et le fait
que c'était un héros un parfait déjà
près de 1000 personnes ont travaillé sur
les dessins les ordinateurs pour le film
et 40 pour le seul personnage d'hercule
s'est dit pourquoi ne pas se tourner
vers l'idéal de règles un visage que
l'on voit dans les musées mais avec un
héros des lèvres charnues des petits
cieux et un long coup et c'est ainsi que
le personnage a évolué à l'intérieur de
ce dessin et on a confère alors ce qu'on
voulait l'adolescent costaud et candide
hercules a parfois un comportement
débile qui n'a pas vraiment plu au gré
de la charge
en fait c'est une comédie musicale
légère et irrévérencieuse qui ne se
prend pas au sérieux mais gare à mes
amis m'appellent mec dont nous c'est que
je n'ai aucun ami
alors est-ce qu'il irait nom est sorti
assez impressionnant hector r qu on nous
quittait le rappel du principal titres
de l'actualité d'aujourd'hui la mort à
l'âge de 67 ans de la chanteuse barbara
laquelle france 2 rendra un hommage ce
soir vers 22h45 présenté par pas la
marée suivi d'un concert de barbara
barbara discrète pudique qui avoue être
dans une chanson qu'elle avait consacré
sa vie à la chanson au public une
histoire qu'elle résumé par cette phrase
ma plus belle histoire d'amour celle où
soir en septembre
vous étiez connu m'attend
ici même sens venez vous en regardez sur
les opposait
sans rien dire c'est là que j'ai compris
tout un coup
je fais mon voyage j'ai foncé mais bon
vous étiez 2